And, the answer that I got is that this more complicated one
has two samples required for splitting.
So basically, it can split until you have a leaf size that's,
that's only one because if you have two samples, the branch and
then it allows it to split, then you can have one and one.
So, we can get very, very finely tuned.
You might only have one point out here.
And, it's drawing this big peninsula, a big,
narrow peninsula all the way out just to grab that one point.
And then, this one, of course, is going to be a lot simpler.
You have to have at least 50 samples in a branch.
Otherwise, you won't be allowed to fit it.
So, you come up with something that's much simpler.